hey everyone its Aires registered nurse
re and calm and in this video I'm going
to be going over an ink Lex practice
question specifically over
bronchodilators in corticosteroids use
for respiratory disease so let's take a
look at our NCLEX question the physician
prescribes a patient to take in health
fluticasone which is flovent h fa and
inhaled albuterol which is ventolin hf a
for the treatment of asthma as the nurse
how will you administer these
medications a first administer the
fluticasone and then give the albuterol
five minutes later
be first administer the albuterol and
then give the fluticasone one minute
later si first administer the
fluticasone and then give the albuterol
immediately or D first administer the
albuterol and then give the fluticasone
five minutes later so this question
wants to know how we are going to
administer this fluticasone and this
albuterol because there is a certain way
in the order of how we should give them
based on how they work so let's take a
look at how they work okay
fluticasone which is also called a flow
vent do you remember what drug this is
what category it falls into it falls
into our corticosteroids and this
patient has asthma so what this
corticosteroids going to do is it's
going to decrease inflammation because
remember it really suppresses our immune
system which is going to take away that
inflammation because that's what it
means is I'm suing its inflaming the
body so it's great at preventing
symptoms in that person with asthma now
one thing I just want to throw in at the
side because it's a nurse you are going
to be administering these corticosteroid
inhalers and I have a whole video where
I went over how to give metered dose
inhaler administration for meds but
whenever you give these corticosteroids
you want to make sure that these
patients gargle and rinse their mouth
with water and spit that water out after
using because these medications can
cause thrush and irritate those mucous
membranes so remember that okay our next
drug is albuterol which is ventolin
which is
type of albuterol now what is that we're
all remember it is a bronchodilator and
specifically it's a short-acting one so
it works for a short period of time and
what does this drug do just as its name
says it's going to open the bronchi and
bronchioles of the lungs so you're going
to get more airflow through those lungs
and this is what a person with asthma
really needs because they have
bronchoconstriction going on so they
need this bronchodilator after they
inhale it it pops those lungs open and
they can breathe and get air now how are
we gonna be giving these who needs to go
first whenever you're giving the inhaler
you have two inhalers once a
bronchodilator once a corticosteroid
well based on how it works what do you
think the answer is you want to give
that bronchodilator first because it's
gonna open up those Airways so this is
what we're gonna give first then we're
going to give the corticosteroid because
once the lungs are nice and open that
corticosteroid whenever they inhale it
can get in those small Airways and
decrease that inflammation because if we
didn't give that bronchodilator first
those Airways wouldn't really be opened
up and that corticosteroids taking it in
there and do its job so we'll give that
second okay but how long do we really
need to wait in between those we need to
give that albuterol time to work to do
its job so we're going to wait five
minutes in between those two doses okay
now let me just throw something out
there just for more information say you
were giving how beautiful and they
needed two puffs and you weren't gonna
be given corticosteroids and this is the
same if you're just going to be giving
corticosteroids so they need to bus of
albuterol you would give one puff and
then you would wait one minute because
it's the same drug and then you would
give the other one okay so just remember
that to keep that straight because
sometimes students get that confused so
our answer is going to be D first
administer albuterol and then give
fluticasone five minutes later okay so
that
sup this NCLEX review question be sure
to check on the other questions in this
series thank you so much for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos